this probably shouldn't come as a
surprise but it looks like star wars
battlefront 2 is a thing an EA has
finally confirmed it he a CFO Blake
Jorgensen said during an earnings call
that battlefront two will have bigger
and better worlds he added that it will
take use of content from the new movies
though he didn't name any outright the
first battlefront only featured content
from the original Star Wars trilogy the
first game has shipped 14 million copies
which is way ahead of the company's
expectations for the shooter on another
note Jorgensen said that EA plans to
release one new star wars game every
year for the next three to four years
the battlefront sica will come out next
year he said it's unclear if he was
referring to calendar year 2017 or ea's
next fiscal year fiscal year just
started on April first we have followed
up with Electronic Arts in an attempt to
get more details he also said that the
star wars action game from dead space
studio visceral and motive is coming
during the next year but again we don't
know if he meant calendar or fiscal on
top of that your ghen ssin mentioned
titanfall developer respawns recently
announced third-person action-adventure
star wars game but he did not provide
any details when it would launch it
sounds like there will be no shortage of
triple-a Star Wars games in the near
future for more details on all these
upcoming games stay tuned to gamespot